- A huge part of CIFAR
is to not only meet,
but regularly talk with,
share ideas with
the true luminaries of my field.
Hi, I'm Yang-Yang Zhou.
I'm a political scientist
and I'm a CIFAR Azrieli Global Scholar.
CIFAR has really allowed me
to expand my global
network in several ways.
I get to belong to a research program
where I have direct access
to top senior scholars.
Another way that CIFAR
has expanded my networks
is through the other global scholars.
Many of them are in the natural sciences
and for these people,
I would never really get to meet them
naturally on my own.
So it's been an amazing opportunity
through CIFAR to get
to talk to them regularly.
One huge benefit of being
a CIFAR Global Scholar
is getting this unrestricted
research funding.
What that means for me is that
I can pursue much more ambitious projects.
It actually helps me
to apply for larger grants later on.
So it allows me to prove
to other funding agencies
that I can take on these large projects
because I already have done it.
Through all of the resources
that CIFAR provides,
the unrestricted funding,
access to the senior scholars of my field
and related fields,
getting to meet all these other peers
in our global scholars,
having professional development workshops,
all of those resources put together
has just really amplified
our initial potential into
something much greater.